i get asked about the topic
of podcasts quite a bit mostly from my
youtube viewers and many of them will
say oh man i love this content could you
put this into a podcaster why don't you
have a
podcast already i'd like to have these
as downloadable
mp3s so i don't have to like keep
streaming your
content using a bandwidth and the answer
is
i actually do have a podcast it's called
sadler's lectures for the time being i
may change the name later
but that's basically what it is i
started it back
in may of 2018
and i've been putting out content and
regularly posting about it
in my social media that is in my twitter
stream
uh in my facebook page
and in linkedin really since that time
and when i first started out i was maybe
doing 10 episodes a month
now i'm up to releasing podcast episodes
almost daily so there's there's you know
over 350 tracks at this point in time
a lot of content and so you know i'd
invite you the link is is right below in
the video description if you're
interested
in my podcast but you haven't already
found out about it or listened to it
just go right there
on soundcloud you can also find it in a
variety of other
formats and platforms like apple
music and whatever google play is now
and a bunch of other things i've even
found by doing searches
that the podcast is aggregated in places
that i
i've never even heard of so it's out
there you just gotta
look for it but again you can go
straight to soundcloud and
find it there if that's what you want to
do so
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
podcast what i'm doing at present
and what i'd really like to do in the
future and you might
want to support that i'll talk more
about that at the end
so sandler's lectures i started taking
some of my philosophical core concept
videos and i've got
probably about 800 of them now and
i would take the the the video file turn
it into a sound file
the ones that i've shot more recently
where i'm using this voice recorder i
just use the voice recorder file
that makes it a lot more useful and then
i try to improve the sound as best as i
can
in some cases there's not that much that
you can do with it
in other cases there's quite a lot i'm
using audacity
which i'm comfortable with i don't want
to try to you know
invest in some really high-end digital
editing software because that's that's
you know not my shtick
right and then i take out all of the
ums and oz and places where i say a word
twice
and long pauses and sounds of me writing
on the blackboard
at least i try to get all that stuff out
of there and then i
you know tack on a little intro and a
little outro and there you got a podcast
episode
so i have been doing that actually i had
my
my daughter helping me out with that at
first but she wasn't really that into
it so i've been doing it myself since
uh 2018 and i've you know put out quite
a few i put together a list
of the different thinkers and this may
not include all of them
but the episodes that are available now
include heraclitus permanentes
plato aristotle epicurus cicero
seneca epictetus augustine anselm
descartes pascal
hume bentham kant hegel mill
kierkegaard dostoyevsky nietzsche marcel
sartre bouvoir camus james
rilke air rawls kohlberg singer
a rant and and i think i probably left
some people off of that
as well and i've also got a few
talks that i gave here and there one
comes to mind the talk that i gave
at the marquette aristotle conference
about thumbos
and its history that's that spirited
part of the soul
i recorded that as i was giving it and i
converted it into a podcast episode and
i'll probably do that with
others in the future so if you go to the
podcast
and you kind of just look around you're
going to find
lectures anywhere from like
8 minutes at the shortest to 30 minutes
at the longest
on all of these different thinkers and
some other key works
it is the same content basically as
you're going to find in core concept
videos
so you know nothing absolutely new there
but
people find them very very helpful and i
use this content
in my online classes i provide it as a
resource to students so you know they
can download it
have it on their phone they go to the
gym they take a walk they're driving
working out whatever they can listen to
me talking about
you know rene descartes and what's going
on in the meditations or
you know about cicero and his different
views on the stoics or the epicureans or
whatever it
happens to be it's totally up to them
so i use these as resources for my own
students
i also provide them to my clients
you know i have a lot of individual
clients and if they're interested in
something i shoot those
podcast episodes to them i say here
check check these resources out right
but the general public seems to be quite
interested in them
and find them useful as well i think
that just a lot of people don't
don't know about them they know about me
more for the youtube videos
and perhaps less for the podcast
episodes
i did go through and take a look at the
stats
and i was pleasantly surprised to find
out
that um all told since the inception
i've had about 140 000
uh listens to to these and you know i
i'm sure that's counting ones that are
coming through
other um formats and platforms as well
but just in the last year in 2020
we had over 100 000 plays
of this this podcast content which is
really gratifying and in december
december was a really bumper month we
had
over 14 000 so getting some traction
i do want to thank one particular
twitter you know user who generates a
lot of cool stuff
and that's true sci-fi that's that's
kelly true love
and you know the the putting
the lists together and having the uh
featuring in the channel that's been
really helpful i
imagine in spreading the word but i do
want to get the word out there a little
bit more which is why i'm shooting this
video the last thing that i
i would like to talk about is
people say okay so you've got a podcast
you're doing these saddlers lectures
that's really nice
um you know you can you i can get this
content elsewhere it's not really
original content because it's
your youtube videos granted it's better
quality
and they're a little bit shorter to
listen to because you took out all of
your you knows
and likes and words like that
when are you going to start doing like
original
podcast content and there's two answers
to that one
is i have done a lot of original podcast
content it's just
basically on other people's podcasts
i've gone on
to so many other people's podcasts
video channels hybrids of the two that
i've got a very long
list of guest appearances i've i've also
done some guest
hosting for example for the sunday stoic
podcast recently
and you could count the wisdom for life
podcast as something
that i do that's the radio show that i
do with with dan hayes here in milwaukee
running every saturday uh while kovit is
going on and then we might go back to
friday times once once we're out of that
so there's all of that right i'm on
podcasts but
you know when it comes to shooting
original podcast or
rather recording original podcast
content
i'm going to do that when i reach a
higher level of
patreon support why because you know i'm
a busy guy
and creating original podcast content
that
that takes a lot of work and a lot of
time and i would need to divert
some time from the other things i'm
doing to creating
that content for people so if if you
want to see that the
key thing to do is to you know support
on patreon i'm going to put a link to
that below
as well and if you like my other stuff
that i do like videos and blog posting
and the public events that i host
online worldwide you might consider
becoming a patreon supporter as well
even if it's at just the one dollar
level give back a little bit
right if you're getting some value out
of the stuff that i do but so podcasting
it is something that i i'm looking
forward eventually to getting into
in a more original way for the time
being it's going to be these
sadler's lectures which people seem to
enjoy
so i'm going to keep cranking them out
and they're really helpful resources
for my philosophy students so i kind of
get a
you know double dip that way so long
story short you know going back to the
key question
hey dr sather why don't you turn these
lectures into podcast episodes or
why don't you have a podcast the answer
is i already have been doing that
link is below you can go and check it
out hope you enjoy it
you